[Music]
although they're the antagonist of the
stories Disney Villains hold a special
place in our hearts they're powerful
manipulative but they're also pretty
messed up stay tuned to see who is our
number one messed up villain don't
forget to give this video a thumbs up
and subscribe to the things now let's
check out the origins of 10 Disney
villains do you want to be a DIY expert
check out our friends at crafty hackers
they have the best hacks crafts and
everything DIY watch their videos for
the best household tricks DIY decor and
fun recipes if you love making crafts
with your friends or just trying new
things they have everything you're
looking for be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any awesome hacks and
crafts
maleficents you can't deny that
Maleficent is one of the most iconic
Disney villains ever but her story is
messed up if you think about it we've
seen her powers in action and we've seen
how she treats her daughter mal but do
you know how she became a villain and
why she is the way she is fairy tales
often feature pretty girls whose life
later gets destroyed by someone with a
much uglier and meaner personality
Maleficent story starts when she doesn't
get invited to the christening party
although the reason behind it is
different depending on which old version
of Sleeping Beauty you read her
reputation gets Maleficent known as the
source of pure evil in all kingdoms as
well as the entire Disney universe but
the origin of her evil is pretty messed
up as we know it it all started when she
didn't receive an invitation to Aurora's
christening party she then put a curse
on the baby Aurora and said she'll lose
her life by the time she's 16 talk about
unreasonable evil that's pretty messed
up isn't it we're sure most people just
struck it off when they're not invited
to birthday parties instead of becoming
the source of all evil Hades Hades has
quite a mysterious origin so we'll talk
about what we know and some of
series the fans have about this Dodd as
wealth this temperamental Greek God was
probably one of the famous Disney
villains we've seen but did you know how
he actually became a villain after he
was humiliated we first see him when
people are celebrating Hercules is birth
he makes a joke that didn't go down well
with the public and that was the start
of his jealousy and rivalry out of all
the villains Katy's personality
resembles a regular human the most well
apart from the fact that he wants to end
Hercules his life and role Olympus but
Hades isn't even that vengeful as he's
clearly out of ideas and how to get
Hercules at some point in the movie so
the fact that he became vengeful just
because he got laughed at by Greek gods
is pretty messed up out of all Disney
villains he's the one that has the most
fans that are actually pretty
sympathetic
although trying to end someone's life
just because people couldn't take your
joke is just a little bit extreme we do
still have a soft spot for Hades as do
many other fans out there but he's still
pretty messed up mother Gothel when it
comes to messed up mother Gothel is
probably one of the most evil villains
ever sure you can argue that she wasn't
as mean as some others but that doesn't
mean that what she did wasn't evil
Mother Gothel whose original name is
Madame Gothel kidnapped a kid just so
she could stay young forever if that's
not narcissistic we're not sure what is
but it doesn't end there many have
pointed out that Mother Gothel actually
has a narcissistic personality disorder
think about it she wants to stay young
so much she'll do anything for it
including kidnapping a child and raising
her in a tower she locked her so-called
daughter away in a tower for 18 years
while she was able to go out as much as
she wanted and she didn't even feel bad
about it talk about being completely
messed up what's even more interesting
about this villain is that many humans
actually possess the same type of
disorder although to be fair if we saw a
flower being created from a single drop
of sunlight we probably think it was
magical too
but seriously Mother Gothel was one
messed up villain that only wanted to
stay young Claude Frollo he might have a
totally ordinary name but he's not an
ordinary guy Claude is just straight-up
scary and if you watched The Hunchback
of Notre Dom as a kid you were probably
really scared of him well to be fair
most adults are still scared of him
unlike most villains Claude was one of
the few that already held the power he
didn't need to rule the world or
anything
he was already pretty powerful but what
he did want was more control Claude evil
mind goes from knowing that no matter
what he does he was right whether it
means taking another person's life or
even burning down an entire city if it's
done because he wants control it must be
right he's extremely manipulative and
conniving and he really doesn't care
about anything or anyone well except for
having to control and having even more
power sounds pretty scary right of
course let's not forget that he tries to
burn Paris after Esmerelda turn him down
he's definitely one of the craziest and
most evil villains there is trying to
burn down a city because someone doesn't
want to be with you come on there's no
need to be this messed up it's there
Cruella De Vil
while some Disney villains don't have a
lot of backstory that truly explains
their origins others definitely do and
it makes them even more twisted than
you'd ever think and Cruella De Vil is
one of those villains in the novel
version of 101 Dalmatians karela was
expelled from school for drinking ink
yep you heard that right she was
drinking ink the novel version of
Cruella also loved eating the strangest
food ever liked dark purple suit black
ice cream and a lot of pepper Carell is
also different from other villains as
she doesn't have any special powers and
she's not a
she just really really really hates dogs
and she really wants the puppies
seriously it's pretty messed up she
actually wanted the puppies and not the
adult dogs because the ferb the puppies
is actually softer Disney fans have also
theorized that it's easier to steal
puppies than it is to steal grown dogs
which makes a good point but it's still
extremely twisted who would have thought
that this messed up villain would
actually become one of the most iconic
Disney villains ever and how on earth
was she able to find someone to make a
child with actually don't answer that
we really don't want to know Jafar sure
Jafar is messed up but you have to admit
that his fancy book combined with his
evil ways is pretty amazing he's a
part-time magician an amateur seer
charming slick but also sick or at least
that's how others described him there
isn't much to too far in terms of
complexity of his character sure he's
the almighty villain but overall he's
actually just another character that
seems to want nothing but power he
betrays Aladdin and then at some point
wants to take his life seems pretty
standard for Disney Villains
right not much is known about Jafar's
past but we found a messed up theory
that might explain more about his origin
a writer named Jon Negroni stated that
Jafar might have been good all along the
writer argued that Jafar seems to be
hypnotizing the Sultan to do his job
think about it Jafar wants to become
by wishing it or marrying into it which
isn't exactly evil is it the writer also
argues that the story has a different
point of view if you see it from Jafar's
perspective so perhaps the massive story
of Jafar isn't so messed up after all
it's the fact that there might be more
to Jafar than you might know the Evil
Queen we're getting closer to our number
one the Evil Queen has a similar messed
up narcissistic personality like Mother
Gothel does she's this vain character
that wants nothing more than to be
called the fairest of them all and she
does it at every price possible but her
story is actually messed up in older
versions of Snow White's the Evil Queen
is actually pretty positive and not
portrayed as such a messed up character
but in the grim version the Queen
actually orders the Huntsman to end Snow
White's life they take pity on her after
capturing her and instead bring organs
of an animal to the Queen the Evil Queen
then eats those organs yep how messed up
is this it gets even worse when you
realize she was meant to eat organs of a
human the Apple doesn't play a part in
the game until way after the Queen
realizes she has no other options and to
go after Snow White herself and what's
even more messed up is that she actually
kind of succeeds in her goal after all
she was able to make Snow White eat the
poisoned Apple right that gets pretty
close to being one of the craziest
villains ever doesn't it Ursula and here
comes the biggest bat of them all you
have to admit that Ursula is one
fabulous Disney villain Ursula's
characters based on the sea witch
character of the Little Mermaid story by
Hans Christian Andersen but the sea
witch in that story was actually pretty
neutral and didn't play a big part which
is also why we never get to learn about
the real backstory of why Ursula is the
way she is
Ursula might not have the Trident but
she's still pretty powerful she's able
to create potions and spells as she
pleases which is pretty cool she also
seems to have weird control over the
weather and can create some pretty
awesome storms so why is she the big bad
well she wants to manipulate those
powers to rule the sea
and overthrow king triton in the process
in the early adaptations of the movie we
learned that Ursula was actually King
Triton sister and Ariel's aunt in the TV
series it's implied she wanted to create
copies of the Trident and overthrow King
Triton that way but of course it didn't
quite work out which is why she wasn't a
part of King Triton's family anymore
Ursula decided to choose power over the
love for her family and if that's not
messed up we're not sure what is Captain
Hook Captain Hook is different than most
villains sure he might seek vengeance
like some of the others and he still
might be the big bad but what Captain
Hook has that others don't is a pretty
interesting origin story hook wasn't his
real name it of course became his name
after he got the hook on his arm his
real name is actually James which isn't
as magnificent but the actual story is
slightly different than the one you
might know hook kidnaps windy which is
how he ends up dueling Peter Pan he is
defeated and has to choose between
surrendering or ending his life he
chooses the latter and throws himself
into the jaws of the crocodiles and
that's how the story ends but another
series the story is just the beginning
we all know Captain Hook lost his hand
because Peter Pan chopped it off and
threw it to the crocodile with an alarm
clock inside his mouth in fact that's
why hook wants revenge
because of his arm not because he wanted
to despite Peter Pan for whatever reason
it's also been noted that Captain Hook
could actually have post-traumatic
stress disorder because of the events
they really makes you feel for the
messed-up life Captain Hook bleeds
doesn't it scar but our favorite Disney
villain is without a doubt scar scar is
manipulative he's cunning he's got that
evil look he's vengeful and he wants
power he's what you would call the
perfect villain
we know that scars real name is actually
taka which means waist in Swahili taka
got his name scar after he managed to
get a scar would be Joe
we tried to fight the boss's team of
buffalos after finding that out is there
still any wonder that this line became a
magnificent villain that actually took
the life of his own brother and
overpowered his throne we don't think so
but that's definitely messed up
in the animated series version of The
Lion King called the lion guard
we learned that scar was actually
previously selected as the leader of the
lion guard but even back then the power
got to his head he abuses power so much
he actually lost him which made him
become even more evil and even more
depressed but it still didn't stop him
from wanting to rule his kingdom
unlike other villains scar succeeded in
his plan and ended mufasa's life in a
battle not a lot of us can actually
forget and that's precisely why he's our
number one messed up villain what do you
think which one of these villains is
your favorites let us know in the
comments and that's all for our video
don't forget to subscribe to the things
and tell us how you felt about this
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]